the Joe Rogan experience like we always
look at you guys and go wow I don't know
how the [ __ ] you guys do it because you
there's not as much like you you might
do the same size venues that we do but
you're splitting the money with all
these [ __ ] people you know and then a
lot of times today the record company
gets a piece they get a piece of
everything right they get a piece your
merchandise
you see bands play really big places and
it's amazing how much money they don't
make yeah or each guy in the band gets
like really yeah huh and then you see
you know someone like a small comedian
playing like a hundred and fifty seater
for two nights two sets a night you know
the the laughs whatever in the Midwest
and you're like wow wow that's a pretty
good weekend like cuz he's just taking
it home in his suitcase yeah you can get
by you get by yeah and you can work you
could work everywhere you know for a
band I think it's more the venue's are
more more limited places you go or more
limited you know and I think that's
interesting that you're it was almost
like a desperation to not have to work a
job as a waiter that kept you just
hustling what did you know I just knew
that the straight world had been in it I
come from it you know minimum wage work
and everything and I knew I couldn't
survive in it because I you know you get
as a young adult you start to figure out
who you are I go okay I'm not an artist
but I'm an artist type I'm an I'm nuts
you can't put me in a straight job I can
pass for normal just because I can't ask
it I can totally do it like you can put
me in a Ralph's of Kroger's a Starbucks
I will totally get in there and hit the
work and clean it all and serve it up
with a smile but I'll be going crazy
inside I will be punching everybody in
those places is going crazy inside I
don't know but um I can't sustain in
that and I haven't had to for many years
I've been lucky I've been in the world
of lunatics since 1981
you know being a crazy person out with
other crazy people and when I look at a
straight job I'm like man I don't think
at this point I could hack it not
because I'm spoiled
just because I've never had to tether my
adult mind
to that I work seven days a week but on
Henry stuff yeah it's me it's not it's a
different thing it's a different thing
yes you enjoy that work yeah and it's
it's way over 60 hours a week I mean
it's I do two shifts usually to eight to
ten hour shifts depending on everywhere
blood well I can't do four hours of
sleep at night but I usually I time I
sleep I hit the stopwatch on the phone
before I go to bed just as clock sleep
patterns I did about six points
something hours of sleep last night
that's good it's good I feel great today
I barely ate and I got in a good workout
and all last night I did a lot of
pull-ups
I played 15 7-inch records and between
flipping them over I got a beam in my
living room it's a beam coming out of
the ceiling that supports me and I just
run over there and just do a bunch of
pull-ups and then go change the record
so you want more music you have to pay
pay and doing all this by yourself all
alone yeah but by bedtime you are hurtin
and ready to sleep so I got good sleep
last night so you mix the workout in
with your enjoyment of music you just
space it in between the song yeah last
night was pulling tonight at the
turntable I'll be listening to more
records all I'll just do sets of
push-ups
next to the turntable that's actually a
smart move because like that's probably
a good interval of rest like get a good
hard workout in and then you listen to a
four-minute song yeah and there but I do
it all night
and it's just I'm not doing 50 sets 50
reps sets I'm doing like 15 to 25 but
I'm doing them for quite a while by the
time I go to bed it's advil time I'm
like do old for this but um I work on
something every day on tour I don't take
vacations I'm not trying to brag I just
can't I can't have you not doing it the
fit whatever the thing is yeah well you
found an interesting way to live life
I don't know anybody like you but it's
working for you yeah it works on all
levels and like I I can sustain I pay my
bills I'm not bored and I get for the
most part to call my own shots and you
seem happy happy when I'm working yeah
yeah happy with the task yeah I value
work
I'm an achievement junkie like if I'm
depressed I just pick something to do
like finish a radio show edit this thing
transcribed this chapter from a notebook
and after I'm done I'm like okay that's
the antidepressant was actually doing
something which is not the worst it's
not booze it's not a pill
it's the treadmill yeah or it's the that
damn thing I got to get it written well
shut up and write it yeah when I'm done
it's like an endorphin thing where I'm
great for another day there was an
article written about happiness and that
was one of the things they said that one
of the things it seems to sustain
people's happiness or facilitate
happiness is accomplishing tasks like
setting goals for yourself accomplishing
those goals and getting this sense of
completion you've actually done the work
and you did it and you discipline
yourself and got through it and that
this is one of the major keys to
happiness for a lot of work for me
totally works for me cuz I mean as well
I've tried everything but drugs so I've
been battling with depression since I
was a little kid you know I just knew I
what is this it's just awful and you
know later I found out it was depression
and I don't want to do drugs I'm not I
just don't want it my brain plus drugs
it's like someone else's idea it
terrifies me so I had to figure out what
do you do and so that's where the gym
you're working out really is a big help
writing but listening to music that is
like kind of my drug you know I just put
the records on and like three songs in
you're like oh there's that feeling
buoyancy neutral it's like floating in
the tank or when you're scuba diving you
get their air just right you're floating
that's how I feel when I have the music
on I'm like ah this is as good as it
gets and that's why I always have you
know record I'm always looking at new
records going to the record store it's
more happiness coming in
[Applause]